[Music]
between the Cape of Saint Maria and
Japan we were four months in 22 days at
which time there were no more than six
besides myself that could stand upon
their feet so we in safety net fall our
anchor about a league from a place
called bungo which time came to us many
boats and we suffered them to come
aboard being not able to resist them
these people did us no harm
neither us understanding the one or the
other within two or three days after our
arrival they came a Jesuit from a place
called Langer sake to which place the
crack of a Macao is yearly want to come
which with other Japanese that were
Christians where our interpreters which
was not to our good our mortal enemies
being our church men nevertheless the
king of bungo the place where we arrived
showed us great friendship for he gave
us a house and land where we landed our
sick men and had all refreshing that was
needful
[Music]
in the which time of our being here the
emperor hearing of us sent presently
five galleys or frigates to us to bring
me to the court where his Highness was
which was distant from bungo about an
eighty English leaks so that as soon as
I came before him he demanded of me or
what country we were so I answered him
on all points for there was nothing that
he demanded not both concerning war and
peace between country and country so
that the particulars here to write would
be too tedious and for that time I was
commanded to prison being well used with
one of our Mariners that came with me to
serve me two days later the Emperor
called me again demanding the reason of
us coming so far I answered we were a
people that sought all friendship with
all nations and to have trade in all
countries bringing such merchandise as
our country did afford in two strange
lands in the way of traffic he demanded
also as concerning the wars between the
Spaniard or Portugal and our country and
the reasons which I gave him to
understand all things which he was glad
to hear as it seemed to me in the end I
was commanded to prison again but my
lodging was bettered in another place
so for 39 days I was in prison hearing
no more news neither of our ship nor
captain whether he were recovered of his
sickness or not nor of the rest of the
company at which time I looked every day
to die to be crossed as the custom of
Justices in Japan as hanging is in our
land in which long time of imprisonment
the Jesuits and the Portugal's
gave many evidences against me and the
rest to the Emperor that we were thieves
and robbers of all nations and were we
suffered to live it should be against
the profit of His Highness in the land
his highness justice being executed the
rest of our nation without doubt should
fear and not come here anymore
thus daily making access to the Emperor
and be curing friends to hastened my
death but God that is always merciful at
need showed mercy unto us and would not
suffer them to have their wills of us in
the end the Emperor gave them answer
that we as yet had not done to him nor
to none of his land any harm or damage
therefore against reason and justice to
put us to death if our countries had
Wars the one with the other
that was no cause that he should put us
to death with which they were out of
heart that they're cruel pretence failed
them for which God be evermore praised
41 days being expired
the Emperor caused me to be brought
before and again demanding of me many
questions more which were too long to
write in conclusion he asked me whether
I were desirous to go to the ship to see
my countrymen I answered very gladly to
which he bade me do so I departed and
was freed from imprisonment so that with
a rejoicing heart I took a boat and went
to our ship where I found the captain
and the rest recovered of their sickness
from the ship all things were taken out
so that the clothes which I took with me
on my back I only had all my instruments
and books were taken all which was done
unknown to the Emperor so in process of
time having knowledge of it he commanded
that they which had
canned goods should restore it to us
back again but it was here in their so
taken that we could not get it again
saying fifty thousand in ready money was
commanded to be given us and in his
presence brought and delivered in the
hands of one that was made our governor
who kept them in his hands to distribute
them unto us as we had need for the
buying of victuals for our men with
other particular changes in the end the
money was divided according to every
man's place so that the part of everyone
being divided everyone took his way
where he thought best this video has
been made possible by World of Tanks
this is also a little clue for sources
voices of the past we'll be looking at
later in the year World of Tanks is a
free to play tank battle game with over
550 tanks and 40 arenas to drive them
around in small tanks big tanks all guns
blazing or sneaking up behind the choice
is yours historical accuracy is also key
here so if you're a big fan of tanks you
definitely won't be disappointed by the
realism and immersion on offer
so if you sign a print account now using
this invite code you'll get seven days
premium access as well as some other
goodies thanks
this land of Japan is a great land and
lieth to the north woods in the latitude
of 8 and 40 degrees and the southernmost
part of it in 5 and 30 degrees and it
lieth east by north and west by south or
west southwest 220 English leagues the
people of this land of Japan are good of
nature courteous above measure and
valiant in war their justice is severely
executed without any partiality upon
transgressors of the law they are
governed in great civility I mean not a
land better governed in the world by
civil policy the people be very
superstitious in their religion and are
off diverse opinions there be many
Jesuits and Franciscan friars in this
land and they have converted many to be
Christians and have many churches in the
land
so in process of four or five years the
Emperor called me as diverse times he
had done before so one time above the
rest he would have me to make him a
small ship I answered that I was no
carpenter and had no knowledge thereof
well do your endeavor say--they if it be
not good it is no matter
[Music]
we're four at his command I built him a
ship of the burden of 80 tons were there
about which ship being made in all
respects as our manner is he coming
aboard to see it liked it very well by
which means I came in more favor with
him so that I came often in his presence
who from time to time he gave me
presents and at length a yearly stipend
to live upon much about seventeen ducats
by the year with two pounds of rice a
day daily now being in such Grace and
favor by reason I learned him some
points of geometry and understanding of
the art of mathematics with other things
I pleased him so that while I said he
would not contrary at which my former
enemies did wander and at this time must
entreat me to do them a friendship which
to both Spanish and Portuguese have I
done
recompense am good for evil
so to past my time and get my living it
has cost me great labor and trouble at
first but God hath blessed my labor in
the end of five years I made
supplication to the king to go out of
this land desiring to see my poor wife
and children according to my conscience
and nature therefore I do pray and
entreat you in the name of Jesus Christ
to do so much as to make my being here
in Japan known to my poor wife and my
two children fatherless which thing is
only my greatest grief of heart and
conscience therefore may this letter
come to any of their hands all the copy
that my friends and Kindred's shall have
news that I do as yet live in this vale
of my sorrowful pilgrimage the which
thing again and again I do desire for
Jesus Christ his sake you shall
understand that the first ship that I
did make I did make a voyage or two in
and then the king commanded me to make
another the which I did being of the
burden of a hundred and twenty tons in
this ship I've made a voyage from Mikko
to eddo being as far from London to the
lizard will the Lands End of England
which in the year of our Lord 1609 the
king lent
governor of Manila to go with 80 of his
men to sail to Acapulco now for my
service which I have done and daily do
being employed in the Emperor's service
he hath given me a living like unto a
lordship in England with 80 or 90
husbands men that be as my slaves or
servants which order like precedent was
never here before given to any stranger
thus God hath provided for me after my
great misery and to him only be my
honour and praise power and glory was
now forever world without end
now whether I shall come out of this
land I know not until this present there
have been no means but now through the
trade of the Hollanders there is means
you shall understand that the Hollanders
have here an indies of money for in
japan there is much silver and gold to
serve for the Hollanders to handle where
they will in the East Indies but the
merchandise which is here vendor will
and ready money is raw silk damask black
taffetas black and red cloth of the
best-led and suchlike goods so now
understanding by this holland ship
lately arrived here that there is a
settled trade by my countrymen in the
East Indies I presume that amongst them
some by the merchants masters or
Mariners must needs know me therefore I
have emboldened myself to write these
few lines in brief being desirous not to
be over tedious to the reader
thus in brief I am constrained to write
hoping that by one means or another in
the process of time I shall hear of my
wife and children and so with patience
I await the goodwill and pleasure of
Almighty God dated in Japan the two and
20th of October 16 11 by or unworthy
friend and servant to command in what I
can
William Adams
you